hi in this video we'll be talking about
the intermediate filament and we would
have a bird's eye view on the
intermediate filament and their assembly
and layer structure as well if we talk
about the cytoskeletal elements of a
cell we would find acting with
microfilaments microtubules and we have
third type which is intermediate
filaments intermediate filaments are
mostly found in tissues which undergoes
a lot of mechanical stress like our skin
which undergoes mechanical stress but
thanks to these intermediate filaments
which protects our skin from any kind of
mechanical stress or damage imagine
you're doing a pull-up in the morning or
stretching your legs your skin is
focusing a lot of stretch forces right
now if these intermediate filaments are
not pair this stretch force would create
breakage in the epithelial layer and
that would be detrimental for your skin
right but thanks to these intermediate
filaments which prevents any kind of
cellular distortion upon stretching
forces or any kind of mechanical
perturbation now unlike acting micro
filaments or microtubules these
intermediate filaments has some unique
property first we talk about their sizes
wrapped in microfilaments are seven
nanometers whereas microtubules are
uniform nanometers in diameter and in
somewhere in between comes the
intermediate filaments ten nanometer in
diameter we would talk about its
structure but let's talk about the
classification of intermediate filaments
so intermediate filaments have very much
resistant to high salt concentration or
detergents and that is the way we purify
these intermediate filaments we put high
salt concentration and detergents which
degrades the actin microfilaments and
microtubules but keep the intermediate
filaments intact so they're very stable
in nature
yet we would understand at the end of
this video they are also very much
dynamic so intermediate filaments is
divided in two broad categories you have
type 1 and type 2 acidic and basic
carotenes these are mostly found in
nails hair glabrous skin and
collectively it is known as situ
correctly there is type 3 which is again
our diverse class which has dis min
which helps our muscle to contract and
it is found in muscle and also GF AP
which are found in astrocytes the type 4
is a class of neuro filaments which
regulates neuronal physiology then the
type 5 is most popular and most common
the nuclear lamins and the type 6
includes nesting which is found in
radial glial progenitors of the
developing brain now lemons are found
just beneath the nuclear membrane lamin
work like a structural support
underneath the membrane on which the
membrane is positioned now glamming has
a common structure it has a in terminal
alpha helical domain then a nuclear
localization signal and then several IG
folds and there are three types of
lemon-lime in a b and c and they are
present in the inner side of the inner
leaflet of the membrane nuclear membrane
and help the nucleus to stay in
structure and when a cell is undergoing
any kind of mechanical shear or any
force it ensures that the nuclear is not
changing its shape or nothing major
happened to the nucleus but this
stability is also a drawback for the
cell because when the cell need to
divide it has to disintegrate its
nucleus and replicates a genomic
material so disintegration of the
nucleus happens in prophase and that
happens by phosphorylation of this lemon
which destabilize them
and thereby the nucleus gets dissolved
the second class is the microf the
microfilaments present in the neurons
they are known as neuro filaments and
they are categorized as neutral filament
l m and H neurons filament l m and H
this nomenclature is based on their
molecular weight L for light H for heavy
so these neuro filaments inside the
neuronal axon helps in axonal growth the
radial growth of the axon now imagine
this is the diameter of the axon and if
the diameter the axon is changed the
impulse conduction velocity would be
also changing right so overall these
neuro filaments has a broad spectrum
role on neuronal physiology then we find
the intermediate filament filaments in
all over our epithelial cells and also
we find specific intermediate filament
proteins in the VL cells especially the
astrocytes this is called glial fibra
Larry acidic protein or GF ap which is
widely used as a astrocyte marker which
is nothing but intermediate filament
carotenes our most diverse classes among
the microfilament and there are like
hard carotene which is present in our
hair nails and glabrous screen the
recite o carotene which are present in
our dermis epidermis cells which gives
also mechanical support to the skin now
unlike microtubule and acting base
microfilament we don't have a globular
subunit in case of the intermediate
filament the basic subunit the
fundamental subunit for intermediate
filament is a rod like structure it's n
terminus and C terminus and in between
there is a long stretch of alpha helix
for simplicity we describe it like this
and let us describe how the intermediate
filament is
so first these these intermediate
filaments subunits assemble in format of
our timer
they coil it on each other and form a
dimer
now these dimers form a staggered pic
drummer and this staggered tetra mer can
assemble to each other on side by side
like a necklace and forming a rope like
structure and this is how eight of these
such detriments assemble to form the
cable or the rope like structure which
is an intermediate filament now
intermediate filament gives the cell
stability mechanical support and they
are very much stable and you have seen
that they are resistant to detergent and
high salt concentration but yet they're
very dynamic because whenever scientist
has put labeled intermediate filament
protein subunits inside a cell inside a
fibroblast after two hours what they
found is several intermediate filaments
are labeled with that fluorescently
labeled highest subunits that means
intermediate filaments though they are
very stable they are also turning over
right and they are dynamic in nature now
intermediate filament just like we saw
in case of the microtubules there are
microtubule associated proteins which
governs the stability of the
microtubules there are certain
intermediate filament associated protein
known as i faps but these proteins are
not well characterized and till date
there are only few proteins which are
known and they are yet to be discovered
these protein cross links the
intermediate filament to each other or
cross links them to the actin
cytoskeleton so one such protein is
flattens so this cross link the
intermediate filament to a micro
filament and that is how even providing
more structural support then there are
days means which are intermediate
filaments found in muscle fibers and
days means can
Nik sarcomere with the zip disk and also
hold mitochondria and nucleus in
position inside a muscle inside a
contractile muscle black teens which are
inter filament intra filament
intermediate filament associated protein
help to clip the best team desmond with
the muscles sarcomere
so click teens are I ABS actually so
this whole this helps in muscle
contraction and especially the forced
construction contraction and it also
helps the muscles from damages this was
an overview of intermediate filaments
and physiologically one of the usage and
what are their functions so in next
video about intermediate filaments I
would be talking real details about
their functionality and the mechanisms I
hope you enjoyed this video if you
enjoyed this video do it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you